you want an Emmy for portraying the role
in baskets and you're nominated again
this year congratulations you're up
against Alec Baldwin you know he's up
against me cuz I won last year yeah my
money's on me yeah I'm gonna put my
money on YouTube I just you know it's
such a great honor just to be nominated
but it is so much better to win that
should be yours yeah we have a clip here
I'll say again I just love love love you
in this role in your company with Zach
Galifianakis is so terrific let's take
over this clip from baskets chair Jim
what are you dreaming about oh who cares
anyway I got you this Kate Oh would you
still have phone from a second-grader it
was the cheapest one they had oh well
this is not up for debate I want you to
have a cell phone I need you to keep in
touch with me I need you to be the kid I
don't have to bail out of jail anymore
the guy who calls and says hey mom I'm
doing good now listen this is a big
chance for you to turn your whole life
around we are now gonna be on an upward
trajectory to just fly spread your wings
but no texting cuz they're 35 cents each
and that I I guess let's like I have
five sisters and I and my mom I look
like my mom there and it is really like
when I watch it it I know I did that
part but I don't I don't even feel like
you don't feel like me yeah it's a
lovely lovely opportunity I'm really
blessed well we're so happy for me I've
got a nomination this year too I like to
shut that up oh that's fantastic
Galifianakis what's your physique alpaca
great guy very good man
you